(soothing music)
- [Julia] Whether your Cesarean Section
was scheduled or unexpected,
it's helpful to know about
the process ahead of time.
In this video, we'll discuss:
Why a Cesarean Section might be needed,
what to expect during
your Cesarean Section,
and what it means to have
a gentle Cesarean Section.
There are many reasons why a patient
may need a Cesarean Section.
There may be factors identified
during your prenatal care
that prompt your provider
to recommend a Cesarean Section.
Such as a placental abnormality,
or if the baby is not
positioned head down.
Alternatively, it may become indicated
during labor if there
is a concerning pattern
on the fetal heart rate tracing,
which is a monitor used
to access the babies
well being during labor.
Another indication is if there is
not sufficient dilation of the cervix,
or if the baby does not seem to be
descending normally through the pelvis.
Your provider will fully
inform you of the risks,
benefits, and reason for
your Cesarean Section.
You will meet anesthesiologist
who will be caring for
you during your procedure.
Most Cesarean Sections will be performed
with regional anesthesia.
Meaning that you will be awake,
but be given an injection in to your back,
also called a block, that prevents you
from feeling pain during the surgery.
You'll be brought back
to the operating room
where you will be prepared for surgery.
After your block is placed,
your team will place a urinary catheter
to drain your bladder,
as well as prepare the
sterile field and drapes.
Everything in your surgery will be done
using careful, sterile protocol
to ensure that your risk
of infection is minimized.
And you will be given breast
feeding safe antibiotics
to further reduce your risk of infection.
When everything is ready,
your chosen support person
will be escorted in to the room
to be with you at the head of the bed.
You may feel pressure, pulling,
or a stretching sensation
during the operation,
but you will not feel anything sharp.
Upon delivery of your baby,
there will be a window in
the curtain that is opened.
Or the drape will be
lowered so that you can see
your baby in the first
moments after birth.
The pediatrics team will
then assess your baby,
and if there are no complications,
or additional care needed,
will bring him or her over to you.
Many hospitals now practice
gentle Cesarean Section.
Where the focus is on reuniting
the mom and baby as soon as possible.
Here at UC San Diego Health
we routinely bring baby back to mom
on the operating room table right away.
And if she feels well enough,
help her put baby skin to
skin, or hold her baby.
Some patients even start nursing
while the Cesarean Section
is being completed.
Other components of a
gentle Cesarean Section
may include classical
music and dimmed lights.
Aside from the operating
lights, of course.
Recovery for a Cesarean Section
does take longer than
for a vaginal delivery.
Immediately after your Cesarean Section,
you will be in a special
post-operative recovery room
for a few hours before
moving to your private
postpartum room with your baby.
Most women will spend three
nights in the hospital
after a Cesarean Section,
and will require pain
medications containing a
small amount of opioids.
It will still be safe to breast feed.
Sometimes it takes slightly
longer for your milk
to come in after a Cesarean Section.
Your lactation team will help support you
and your baby to meet
your breast feeding goals
during this transition.
Once you are home, recovery will continue
for four to six weeks.
Avoiding lifting anything
heavier than 15 pounds
during this time is important
to help your body to heal.
It's important to ask questions
or voice any concerns or
requests that you have
before, during, or after
your Cesarean Section.
Your treatment team cares
that your experience is
as smooth as possible
with the ultimate goal of healthy mom
and healthy baby.
(soothing music)